foreign
[Music]
of the meme trading Boom the grip U.S
stock markets Jake Freeman a 20 year old
college student from New Jersey made
over 110 million dollars on an
inexplicable surge in ailing U.S
retailer Bed Bath and Beyond
the windfall became a global sensation
because of its size in Freeman's age
Freeman was introduced to investing as a
teenager by his uncle at the age of 16
he interned at a quantitative hedge fund
where he and its founder published two
academic papers examining Financial
theories on debt defaults and options
contracts the fund's founder Vivek
Kapoor called Jake quote a Smart Sharp
guy with a dense set of neurons that can
address any problem without Dogma
Freeman an Applied Mathematics student
at the University of Southern California
attempted to put his theories into
practice he focused on one soaring meme
stocks such as AMC GameStop and bed bath
which had fallen sharply day Traders had
engineered short squeezes on funds that
wagered these stocks would fall Freeman
believed that the company's volatility
evident in options prices could be used
to raise emergency cash
pharmacy Rite Aid became his next Target
before he turned his attention to bed
bath quote I noticed how with the right
sort of realigning of their depth they
could really reduce their bankruptcy
thesis said Freeman he raised Millions
from nearby investors and family and
bought six percent of bed bath for 15
million dollars he proposed that bed
bath offer bondholders warrants and
convertible notes to cut its debt the
unconventional suggestion was similar to
a failed maneuver attempted by rental
car agency Hertz in 2020. on July 20th
Freeman disclosed The Proposal then
began discussing his investment on
Twitter and Reddit in August bed bath
shares started soaring amid interest
from posters on Reddit they Rose further
after GameStop chair Ryan Cohen a meme
stock figurehead filed documents
detailing a previous purchase of call
options
in August Freeman decided that the rally
had pushed bed bath shares too high and
sold his stake for an over 110 million
dollar game
[Music]